[Music]  I didn't even know you two were a couple  at your age going on a trip with the  young man that that means something what  do you think you won't find a better  place on the barge this man here is  captain for true shape the officer in  charge of investigating my father's case  the maje wasn't built to carry so many  people  there's no other way but these people  down the goddamn roof it's pop out it's  falling to pieces why would I lie to you  about this it will be up to us to save  Leningrad we will do what is required on  that short is where we need to be that's  you know that her father's a traitors  enemy the people German spy are you  aware of that I want the two of you been  together it looks like you figured  everything out about you  the latest weather report from Lake  Ladoga sir strong winds high waves low  cloud cover with a barges  [Music]  [Music]  there's no one's a-save  [Music]  you